ich habe gehofft es sich nach zwei
jahren pause hier persönlich teilnehmen
kann
an der arbeit des menschenrechtsrates
der un muss aber per video gesprochen
das sind ein ergebnis der maßnahmen
der europäischen union die einschränkung
der bewegung
das sind illegitim und sanktionen die
stoffe genutzt werden rom von einem
ehrlichen dialog auf augenhöhe aus dem
weg zu gehen
sie muss zu diesem dialog die situation
in der welt wird nicht einfacher credit
graviert die wichtigste ursache besteht
darin dass die usa und ihre verbündeten
allen anderen
mitglied der weltgemeinschaft ihre
weltordnung aufzwingen und wozu das
führt für die menschenrechte das sehen
wir gut am beispiel der ukraine die
politik des kollektiven wissens mit
washington an der spitze hat dazu
geführt dass seit 2014 das geber regime
mit dem eigenen
mit allen die mit den neonazistischen
werten des mannes nicht einverstanden
sind
mit den aktionen der regierung die
menschenrechte verletzen und die rechte
der nationalen minderheiten
verletzten und auch letztendlich die
verfassung des 1 des eigenen landes die
neofaschisten die die macht in kiel
führungen haben haben ein c rohr vom
zaun gebrochen kiel führt eine
aggressive die ratifizierung und zwangs
als simulierung durchgeführt menschen
die sich als russen betrachten und ihre
identität ihre sprache ihre kultur
bewahren wollen den letzten mal die
lässt man verstehen dass sie fremd sind
iso green talents ehrt sie ob die
personen genannt und hat ihn empfohlen
aus der ukraine zu verschwinden es geht
hier auch um das gesetz um indigene
bevölkerungsteile und da haben die
russen keinen platz gefunden die seit
jahrhunderten erleben das entspricht der
gesetzgebung nazi-deutschland
verjagt die russische sprache aus den
alltäglichen leben häufig kommt zur
situation wo man für das recht die
eigene muttersprache zu verwenden nicht
nur den job verliert sondern auch die
gesundheit oder leben stellen sie sich
vor dass irland die englische sprache
verbieten würde in belgien
die französische italien die deutsch
aber die frontale attacke auf die
russische sprache in der ukraine
ruft beim aufgeklärten westen keine
reaktion hervor
anders denken führt immer zu schwersten
folgen stellte prozess der säuberung der
regierungsbehörden von loyalen
angestellten wird fortgeführt und die
oberste rada hat noch ein gesetz
verabschiedet das illustre verlust ratio
nhs gesetz das es den behörden
ermöglicht andersdenkende und
oppositionelle zu verfolgen
viele kanäle dürfen nicht mehr arbeiten
andere massenmedien
es kommt zur repression gegen eigene
bürger auch gegen parlaments abgeordnete
es geht ja hier auch um die verletzung
der meinungsfreiheit
lügen über den zweiten weltkrieg werden
verbreitet anhänger hitlers werden zu
helden erklären und die echten helden
die ein g verschissen fallen der
vergessenheit anheim
kriegsverbrecher die im dritten reich
mit gekämpft haben sind die neuen helden
und ein ausdruck dieses kurses
vom 23 februar der gesetzesentwurf
das duo green aus regierungs austritt
und
auf diesem hintergrund ist das verhalten
von so lenz geht an den gleichen tagen
gesagt dass er
das gedenken an seinen großvater
hochhält schnitt der in der roten armee
mitgekämpft hat das regime berührt auch
ein intimes einen intimen bereich die
privaten
lebensräume der menschen die
religionsfreiheit
es ist zu einer kirchenspaltung gekommen
auch mit der hilfe washington es jetzt
gibt es die ukrainisch orthodoxe kirche
entgegen die kanonische
orthodoxe kirche in der ukraine die zum
moskauer basra hat gehört millionen
gemeindemitglieder und kirchliche
würdenträger werden
verfolgen das ist ein verstoß gegen die
religionsfreiheit und diese ganzen
intakten attacken und den neofaschismus
usa kanada die länder der eu beschließen
da die augen und bezeichnen sich auch
noch als maßeinheit für die für
demokratie